who was carl
growing up family parents upbringing
you know school how was he in school
what stories do we need to know about
him
that influenced him to become who he
ended up becoming with writing the book
with engels communist manifesto
yeah he was he was born in trier germany
may 5th 1818.
so trier is spelled like trier t-r-i-e-r
and it was it was one of the most
religious cities in all of germany
um very heavily roman catholic in fact
the ancient cathedral in trier
was built in the 320s the 320s not the
1320s the 320s around the year 330
and it was built financed by helena
saint helena the mother of constantine
of all things
who made a pilgrimage to the holy land
and came back
with all sorts of artifacts
she believes that she found the actual
cross the christ was crucified on
the actual crown of thorns which to this
day
allegedly exis allegedly is the cross of
thorns that's
in notre dame in paris and she even
believes that she found the holy robe
which was the
the robe that christ wore on the way to
the crucifixion that the roman soldiers
cast lots for at the at the feet at the
feet of christ of the crucifix
that holy robe is in the cathedral and
trailer
so marx grows up in a very very
religious city
his father um the family was jewish
many rabbis in the family background
pretty faithful family
father converted to lutheranism probably
at least in part
under the social pressures of the day
but the father always believed in god
patrick and he even said he would tell
carl he'd say you know
believing in god is a good thing for a
young man carl right it gives you some
accountability
something beyond yourself a sense of
ethics
right kind of a sense of absolute
something that you could follow
carl was baptized around the age of 5
1823 1824 became a fairly
passionate christian through his teen
years
and then fled the faith in college where
probably the biggest influence in
college was a very anti-semitic theology
professor that he had named bruno bauer
who was such a bad theology professor
that
that the other the other faculty members
ran him out of the college he was he was
teaching
heresy and so so bruno bauer and his
favorite student karl marx together in
1841
started what they called an archives of
atheism
a a journal of atheism which quickly
folded because they couldn't get any
support for it
but at that point he was um he pretty
much
put religion behind him in the 1840s
and became a pretty uh militant
aggressive atheist
after that was there a follow-up between
him and his dad and his parents or no oh
yeah
what was the following what happened i i
quote a chilling letter in
in the devil and karl marx i think it
was march 2nd 1837 march 1837
and it's a letter between marx and his
father
and uh the father is very harsh toward
him
in that letter and i i really think it's
excessively harsh but but the
marx loved his father admired his father
and after that the father died not long
after that
and marx from there on looked at his
parents while his mom
primarily for money marx was horrible
about making money an absolute deadbeat
dad who would not provide for his wife
would not provide for his children
both his mother and his wife expressed
the wish that
carl would start earning some capital
instead of just writing about capital
he he sent his wife out begging for
money to his wife's in-laws
uh carl went to his own in-laws the the
only way
that that marx was able to do what he
did was was because of friedrich ingalls
because ingalls inherited a pile of
money from his capitalist wealthy
industrialist father
and and ingles became marx's sugar daddy
his subsidizer and frankly ingles was
pretty sick of it too
the way that carl all the time was was
pumping him for money
constantly mark marx refused to earn
or earn a living the the family his wife
jenny
jenny's family was so upset at carl's
refusal to make any money
that the family lent their nursemaid a
girl named
helene demuth who had grown up with
jenny the family loaned her out to carl
and jenny
and they called they called her lynchin
carl refused to pay her a penny
and and in fact carl got her pregnant
behind jenny's back and then luncheon
helene had a baby carl refused to
admit that the child was his and of
course
refused to pay the child a penny a penny
of child support
so you know the time the type of world
that marx was looking to create
would have been a world where where the
government took care of somebody like
carl
well he sat around on his butt with
carbuncles
and boils and refusing to bathe
and never earned a dollar i mean that's
the type of world that that he was
looking to create for himself what
was his logic like what was his motive
and logic behind
that way of thinking in his own personal
life
yes and the way he was like i'm not i'm
refusing to help out my wife
you know anybody what was his logic to
say i'm not moving people need to take
care of me not me taking care of them
was it because
he felt he was above people or because
he felt people
owed him something because of being
mistreated or what what was it
i don't think it was the latter he did
feel that people owed him something
he was he was very bitter and he was
very angry and and
superior to others oh yeah i mean marx
was
it was hard for marx ever to keep a
friend he eventually ran afoul of
everybody
um i quote some of the vitriol between
him and mikhail bakunin
who wrote god on uh god the state in
revolution no i'm messing that up
but but he was another militant atheist
and said oh here's carl flinging his
bile at me now
like he does at everybody and uh ingalls
was one of the only people who hung with
him
and in fact when when engel's mistress
died
ingalls ingalls did not believe in
marriage so he refused to marry
any of the women that he lived with but
he loved this woman
and carl wrote him a note where i mean
even the marx biographers the
hagiographers the people who like marx
say oh this was really offensive this
was a low blow by marx
marks in the first one or two three
lines
acknowledges the death of ingles um
girlfriend
and then gets on to the next 20 30 lines
with a more important question
of asking ingles for more money and
engels was so offended by this he wrote
back this diatribe letter
even my capitalist friends show more
sympathy than you
and and he almost cut marks off
permanently
at that point but he came to realize
that marx was that's just how marx was
you know he's what was thought about
himself what was his knowledge
what was engel's reasoning for wanting
to financially support marx what was
what's in it for him yeah the cause
the cause of communism and when ingalls
first met
marx he he referred to him in a poem as
the monster of ten thousand devils
the monster of ten thousand devils and
he talks about this poem
this black man from trier right he's
using black here
in the in the sense of darkened right
like like darkened figure this
foreboding presence
we had the strange allure too and
engel's faith story is much more
complicated
he had grown up a christian never really
wanted to leave the faith and always had
this kind of
so he felt carl like pulling him over to
the dark side almost
but they formed this partnership the
communist manifesto
i quote in the book mark's um ingles
writing to marx
carl give a little more thought to the
communist confession of
faith i think we should drop the
catechetical form
and just call it the manifesto so they
even talked about this document that
they were writing
in religious like language so this
became
something deeper for them this was their
calling right
this this was their vocation this was
this was like almost a religious
enterprise to them
and they hung in there and became
lifetime partners and
wrote pretty much um everything together
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye